Film Courage: What is a popular film that
script breaks all the screenwriting rules
and yet is still a success?
How often does this happen and is this something
that bothers you in any way?
John Truby: That’s an interesting question
and you really have to go to that concept
of screenwriting rules.
And in my Anatomy of Story classes I talk
about all of the fundamental key elements
to be in your script for it to be a great
story.
We are literally talking about how you tell
a great story.
In that sense there is no popular film that
I can tell you that breaks those rules.
Because we’re talking about two different
concepts of what that rule means.
Most people think about the Rules of Writing.
They are really talking about these very conventional
type of ideas, about what makes a good script.
I’m not interested in that because that
is mechanical writing or that is paint-by-numbers
script writing.
And that simply won’t work.
When I talk about the rules of good story,
I’m talking about key elements way under
the surface that link a story together so
it builds steadily from beginning to end.
Now at that level of story, what I call the
Grammar of Drama, a story can build so that
it has the greatest impact on the audience.
There is no way to write a great script that
doesn’t hit those beats.
Now, here is the qualify which is when you
transcend a genre, when you use (for example)
advanced storytelling techniques you come
up with a story that appears to break those
basic rules.
But it doesn’t.
What it’s simply doing is coming up with
characters and story structures that are complex,
they are not the simple chronological beginning-to-end
type of story.
And these stories might have a main character
who is “unlikable.”
That’s one of those conventional rules that
I mentioned that you hear when you’re first
starting out as a writer “Well I have to
have a likable hero.”
No…that is false.
So it is very important for writers to understand
what these “rules” are that make a great
story and these so called conventional rules
that are not true.
They are certainly not true now and they probably
never were.